je le rappelais tout à l'heure en
plaisantant je ne devrais pas à l'om est
champion de france pour la cinquième
année consécutive un exploit unique dans
les annales du football
brillante saison terminée par une
brillante victoire sur le psg 3-1 hier
dans le stade vélodrome
une fête quelque peu ternie par des
agissements des bills de quelques
supporteurs parisiens irresponsable
commentaires christophe duchiron le
football est un jeu
sauf bien sûr quand certains supporters
n'ont pas envie de s'amuser
provocation violence supporters en cage
jets de fumigènes dans les tribunes 14
blessés le psg ne mérite pas ses
supporters on n'a pas de fonction
certainement
aussi dur que la colle
le football est un jeu sauf bien sûr
quand les joueurs oublient de jouer dans
ces moments là la violence est souvent
trop venir partager le football devient
alors une salle petite guerre ainsi le
football se fait d'ombré de lumière
lumière brillante éclatante avec cette
fabuleuse action conclue en but par
basile boli un but d'artiste
quand les joueurs s'en donne la peine le
football est un jeu merveilleux presque
un art
marseille champion d'europe a donc battu
le psg 3 buts à 1
marseille champion de france pour la
cinquième fois consécutive
joli palmarès évidemment maintenant s'il
y avait un palmarès de la bêtise ce
match figurait sans doute dans le haut
du classement quatre jours